But take a look at how this changes our diagram.
In the old version, we had only one function object because it
had been defined outside of the carlike function.
Now, as a result of the fact that we moved the source code for
that move method up into the body of the carlike function, we now
have a new function being generated every time we run the carlike function.
This is a high price to pay for the simplicity of having all of your code show
up at the same level of indentation inside the body of the carlike function.
People are often confused why it would be the case that moving the function
definition up into the body of this function would result in there being many
move methods, many different function objects, one per instance of a car.
Let's open a new file to examine that point.
This simple maker function builds and returns a brand new object.
So after calling makeAnObject twice and
storing each of the results in a variable, do you expect the two objects that
are stored in these two variables to be the exact same or to be two objects that
look quite similar because of the similarities in their properties.
Another way of asking this is would they pass a strict comparison of
their identity using triple equals?